deutschland ist eine exportnation aber
die landessprache gilt nicht als
gefragtes gut
grund dafür könnte eine gewisse
schwellenangst sein
das weltweite image der deutschen
sprache ist noch ausbaufähig sehr streng
und ich denke eine er militärische
sprache
es klingt etwas hart vielleicht doch
schon ziemlich schroff
trotzdem erlebt deutsch seit einigen
jahren einen popularitätsschub die
sprachkurse an den goethe instituten
sind stark nachgefragt deutsch zählt
nach englisch französisch und chinesisch
zu den beliebtesten fremdsprachen direkt
der linguist ulrich ammon untersucht die
globale verbreitung des deutschen in
seinem buch die stellung der deutschen
sprache in der welt hat er zahlen
gesammelt und liefert gründe für den
zuwachs das ist ein beleg dafür dass das
ansehen deutschlands in der welt in der
letzten zeit gewachsen ist und die haupt
basis dafür ist die wirtschaftliche
stabilität um das rankt sich alles
andere strahlt aus auf alles andere das
man dann plötzlich auch die deutsche
kultur wieder interessant
wer die landessprache spricht hat
bessere jobaussichten bei deutschen
unternehmen auch sportliche erfolge wie
die der deutschen
fußball-nationalmannschaft fördern das
interesse
und dann ist er ja noch berlin die
deutsche hauptstadt gilt nach wie vor
als ob
einen sprachkurs in berlin ist darum
besonders populär
hier am gs sprachzentrum kommen 280
schüler aus 23 nationen zusammen einige
davon sind schon seit jahren dabei und
haben diverse favoriten in dem für seine
zusammengesetzten worte berüchtigten
sprachschatz gefunden
die schüler kommen aus südamerika asien
und vor allem aus den ländern südeuropas
damit ist die klasse ein fast
repräsentatives abbild der regionen in
denen deutsch besonders gefragt ist
kopfzerbrechen bereitet allen hier die
grammatik etwa der brasilianerin adriana
monteiro viera ich werde nie deutsch
beherrschen aber ich werde immer
versuchen einige deutsche begriffe haben
es in anderen sprachen zu mode wörtern
gebracht etwa zeitgeist gemütlichkeit
oder die angesagte vorsilbe über
germanisten sind neuerdings auch in der
internationalen restaurant und bar szene
hätte so heißt ein restaurant in new
york in kopenhagen gibt es bier war und
in london das katzenjammers
der journalist sven siedenberg hat den
ausgewanderten deutschen wörtern
nachgespürt sein buch besserwisser beim
kaffeeklatsch in stellt die populärsten
beispiele vor das deutsche hat
sicherlich ein stück exotik zu bieten
man verschafft sich damit ein bisschen
das gefühl etwas besonderes zu sein man
verschafft sich vielleicht auch das
gefühl mit zur apa dazu gehören das
verspürt aber längst nicht jeder
deutschland die vorurteile gegen die
sprache halten sich beständig etwa in
venezuela der heimat von ernesto is a
cool
ja das ist eine ganz schwierige sprache
ist und auch ganz hat es heute nicht so
schön nicht an
kein wunder noch heute wird in hollywood
der kasernenhofton der nazis als die
mittel eingesetzt
mit ihren betrunkenen rüpelhaften
benehmen strapaziert sie schreien immer
und sie spricht sehr stark und immer
hart der deutschen rockband rammstein
gelang mit der überspitzung dieses
teutonen thum sogar eine weltkarriere
[Musik]
und rammstein weckte damit vor allem bei
ausländischen jugendlichen das interesse
an der sprache
am anfang konnte ich keine sprechen und
habe ich das geübt mit
wie sagst du wie sagt man mit wasser
oder nach zähneputzen
ein riesen hit bei youtube war dieses
video das den klang des deutschen mit
dem anderer sprachen vergleicht von
wegen
deutsch ist bierernst die sprache hat
durchaus ihre positiven seiten
[Musik]